one thing that immediately jumps to mind
is a man who I saw who was completely
psychotic and due to these delusional
beliefs he uh he killed his mother and
then cut her open and he he basically
tried to wear her like a
[Music]
suit hello everybody my name is Dr
Shaham Das I'm a consultant forensic
psychiatrist and a YouTuber and I'm here
today to answer your questions from the
honesty box let's get
started
so first question what do you actually
do that is an important question so I'm
a forensic psychiatrist right so a
psychiatrist is a medical doctor who
deals with and treats mental illness a
forensic psychiatrist does that but with
people who either have committed a
seriously violent crime or other levels
of violence who definitely have or are
suspected of having a mental illness I
also work as an expert witness so I go
to these trials and I give evidence in
court what are the typical personality
traits and behaviors of a serial killer
uh interesting question it's quite hard
to answer because there isn't really
typical serial killers and they're so
infrequent that it's hard to really get
an understanding of of what is normal
typical but generally speaking they're
they're classed into two categories
right so there's organized serial
killers and disorganized serial killers
so organized serial killers they tend to
as the name suggest they plan their acts
in advance they Savor the moment they
often like to think about it afterwards
they take momentums or reminders or
trophies of their victims and sometimes
they masturbate over them at a later
time to to gain the sexual pleasure uh
they put in a lot of time and Research
into their victims so they might stalk
them for months uh so Ted Bundy comes to
mind he he absolutely did Recon on his
victims for for several weeks in advance
uh they tend to be quite intelligent and
they tend to blend in really well into
society which makes them even more
terrifying I think and and even more
hard to detect whereas disorganized
serial killers are pretty much the
opposite of all of those things so they
don't particularly plan out the killings
they just they have this like murderous
rage that just comes out in a frenzy uh
and sometimes they just quite
impulsively just decide to kill Like a
Stranger they don't cover their marks
particularly well but because they don't
have a particular type or a Target it
also means that they're harder to catch
in some ways they often leave the body
at the scene of the crime they don't
have the the patience uh or the
wherewith all at that time to actually
you know try and cover up their tracks
um and they tend to have a lower IQ and
they tend to to struggle to fit into
society so those are people that in
retrospect you think are a bit weird
what is the most violent crime you've
worked on in terms of the actual level
of violence in one incident one thing
that immediately jumps to mind is a man
who I saw who was completely psychotic
and due to these delusional beliefs he
uh he killed his mother and then cut her
open and he basically tried to wear her
like a suit and this was all related to
psychotic beliefs delusional beliefs
that he had to do this to kind of
control these demons um So that
obviously sticks out of my mind I think
one of the most kind of shocking cases
that I've seen was of a young
18-year-old girl who became psychotic
had these delusional beliefs again about
demons and she was babysitting her
three-year-old nephew and she smothered
and killed him because she thought that
she had to do this to save him from the
afterlife
and she thought that she had the powers
to to resurrect uh him because she
suffered from these grandio delusions so
that's also a shocking level of violence
and as you'd imagine is quite is quite a
bit of emotional roller coaster for
somebody like me assessing somebody like
her why am I obsessed with True Crime uh
I don't know about you individual
question ask her but in terms of people
in general I think there's a number of
reasons first of all there is genuine
curiosity so I think human are drawn to
the maaba I think part of it is fear so
we all part of us are all all scared of
being a victim of crime so we like to
know the motivations of murderers serial
killers rapists etc etc um and I think
part of it is escapism really isn't it
so to to watch like a well-made true
crime documentary you put yourself in
the perspective of the detective don't
you so you look out for the own Clues
and I think there's a an enjoyment in
playing along I read that women uh
overwhelming majority of people that
like have an interest in True Crime do
you think that's true or absolutely yeah
so if I go to so crime con is is a an
event that I speak at regularly and I
would say it is 70% women not entirely
sure what that is because Men by far
commit much much higher levels of
violence in everyday life in society
than women do but women seem to be more
interested in it maybe it's because of
that fear that I mentioned before so
maybe it's because some women feel more
vulnerable so they want to to kind of
arm themselves with the knowledge and
the tools to avoid violence and avoid
those um sort of difficult situations
how can you tell if somebody is a
psychopath um well I suppose for me it's
relatively easy right because I have
that patient detained under the mental
health act they're in my hospital so I
have lots of sources of information but
I think the more interesting version of
this question is how do you how can you
tell if somebody is a psychopath like in
real life out in the real world and my
answer to that think is actually is
quite difficult because Psychopaths by
the very nature are quite manipulative
and they're good at camouflaging
themselves but there are telltale signs
so a true psychopath will it kind of
they'll try and exploit you for for
anything that they can get from you
whether it's money whether it's
friendship whether it's sex and they're
quite narcissistic so everything's about
them and I suppose another way is to
look at their social circle of friends
so Psychopaths because they use people
they tend not to have deep friendships
they have a large circle of friends and
they know a lot of people they kind of
use them and then throw them away so
that is a way of telling what's the um
difference between a psychopath and a
sociopath yeah good question so a
psychopath is a formal medical term so
if you ask 50 Forensic psychiatrists
that' all give you the same answer
sociopath is more of an informal term so
different people will say different
things in terms of their similarities
they they manipulate they lack empathy
they don't care about other people and
they will stab other people in the back
in terms of the differences sociopaths
are less able to contain their emotions
right so if you piss off a a psychopath
they will get revenge on you later their
revenge is a is a dish that serve cold
whereas a sociopath will will kind of
they can't contain their emotions
they'll blurt out what they're feeling
and they'll get angry at you um and also
sociopaths tend to have lower IQs and
they live on the fringes of society so
Psychopaths can blend in a lot easier in
in everyday life so they could be your
next door neighbor they could be on your
golf team what is the criteria for
Broadmore so Broadmore is a high secure
Hospital the criteria tend to be well
first of all you have to have a mental
illness right so there has to be a
reason for you to have a psychiatrist a
forensic psychiatrist and and a team of
nurses physiotherapists occupational
therapists to treat you in the first
place you have to have a mental illness
that can be treated through medication
through therapy but for the level of
violence it is as you'd expect it to be
extremely high so multiple murders and
multiple sexual assaults people that
have been in other secure units and have
not gotten better after many years the
other thing that people probably don't
know uh or it's probably not as
publicized as well is that Broadmore
also takes people that are not
necessarily that violent but have other
security risks like repeated arsonists
who kept setting fires in other
psychiatric Wards it's much harder to to
set fire in Broadmore simply because of
the level of security why do women fall
in love with with serial killers this is
a great question um something that I've
been asked about before and it's it's a
complicated question I think so of first
of all there's a term for it so we
psychiatrists we like to sound clever
than we actually are we call it
hybristophilia and I think the vast
majority of times it's because the women
themselves are actually quite damaged so
they've come from abusive relationships
whether it's you know their own their
own upbringing or whether it's romantic
Partners so they've been the victims of
domestic violence and they gravitate
towards what is familiar rather rather
than gravitating towards what it's safe
but and here's the twist they try and
find relationships where they can be in
control so if you're in a relationship
with a serial killer a murderer you get
to control the visits you get to control
the communications you know that he's
not off gallivanting and cheating on you
so so I think that's part of the
motivation but I also think there's some
that have this like savior complex so
for whatever reason maybe they they
weren't they weren't nurtured enough
when they were children children so they
they try and kind of project their own
deficiencies onto somebody else and
there isn't much more of a savior
complex then trying to rehabilitate like
a serial killer most dangerous mental
illness I suppose it it depends on
whether you're talking quality or
quantity of violence so quantity of
violence undoubtedly that would be
something like antisocial personality
disorder so that's somebody who
naturally is callous doesn't care about
others and is impulsive so they tend to
be career criminals like you know um
thugs drug dealers Etc so they're the
kind of people that you go through the
system you try and treat them and they
will keep re offending in terms of
oneoff instances of violence I'd say
schizophrenia because even though the
vast majority of people with this
disorder aren't dangerous when they
become dangerous they can do something
that's completely erratic so I've talked
already about an 18-year-old girl who
killed a nephew because of psychotic
beliefs just last month I saw somebody
who attacked their neighbor with a
baseball bat because in his deluded mind
he was convinced this person was a
pedophile not true so that because their
beliefs can be so um so extreme they can
sometimes lash out with um unexpected
violence how can you tell if someone is
lying that is a good question and I
think it is uh widely misunderstood by
most people the honest answer is you
can't I can't you can't so there have
been experiments in the past where
they've had people who've like given a a
a correct and a false narrative and
they've got professionals to try and
tell the difference they've done it with
police officers they've done it with
judges and the overwhelming results is
that people are rubbish at spotting when
people lie so people get it right
slightly above 50% of the time even even
detectives so that's only slightly
better than flipping a coin so part of
it is because some people have their
biases so they want to believe or they
make a prejudgment on who they're
talking to and automatically decide in
their heads whether they're telling a
lie or not whether they're guilty or not
some people are really good at lying so
some people have the kind of um
creativity to change their stories on
the spot some people lack the fear in in
being under pressure when they're lying
and also I think there's this this kind
of assumption that there's that there's
these of ticks or these body language
experts that go on YouTube who assess
when people are lying and it's all Bs
and you can tell that because if it was
accurate then you wouldn't need a a
trial system you wouldn't need
detectives you just put people on the
stand and you get an expert to tell
whether they're lying or not and I think
the reason is because as well as some
people being really good at lying is
that when people have ticks it's
individual to them so you see these
YouTubers that say if somebody's looking
up and to the left and they're lying but
it's it's so different between different
people that there's no real way of
consistently knowing if somebody's lying
unless you know that person intimately
yourself and the other thing is that
both lie detectors and people who think
they can detect
lies only really detect discomfort and
fear right so another way of saying that
is let's say hypothetically there's uh
you have two suspects for murder right
and one is telling the truth but they're
really really nervous because they know
that they could potentially go to prison
for for uh lying they might come across
as uncomfortable they might be fidgety
they might be stammering but they're
still telling the truth they're not
lying versus you might have somebody who
lacks fear like a psychopath who
committed the crime they might be really
good at hiding their discomfort and
still be lying so none of it is accurate
I've heard that 12% of CEOs are
psychopaths is this true I think 12% is
a bit High to be honest I think from my
knowledge it's more around four or 5% of
CEOs are psychopaths psychopaths people
who lack empathy who are quite cold and
callous and in the corporate world
basically can stab their colleagues in
the back and sleep well at night so as
you can see people like that can rise
quite high up the corporate ladder so as
well as lacking empathy they tend to be
quite Charming Psychopaths so they can
build business relationships and
business networks and also they take
risks so they have such a low fear
response that Psychopaths don't mind
gambling with their own or other
people's money and in some if the risks
work out they can rise uh amongst within
the corporate world how common is it for
offenders to fake mental illness can you
tell so yeah it is actually relatively
common so I'd say probably every two to
three months in my line of work
assessing uh individuals who've
committed crimes to write to give
evidence in court every two or 3 months
I'll come across somebody who's either
completely fabricated or more often kind
of exaggerating symptoms of mental
illness and to be honest with you it is
very easy to tell uh for a number of
reasons firstly because before I go and
see them I look at all the evidence so
I'm not just taking their presentation
in front of me into account I'm looking
at all the medical notes for the actual
offense let's say um let's say somebody
stabed somebody in there the CCTV
footage after an argument in the pub I'm
looking at that CCTV footage I'm looking
at the witness statements by all the
people people around them I'm looking at
the witness statement potentially of the
victim I'm reading the police interview
transcripts when that person's been
arrested and it's been interviewed
usually within 24 hours so I've got so
much objective information after I've
assessed them I look at evidence of how
they've been now so if they're remanded
and prison I speak to the prison
officers if they're already sectioned in
a psychiatric hospital I speak to the
nurses and I'm looking for consistency
so if somebody tells me they're hearing
voices and and voices told them to stab
somebody which is quite common is
commonly a complaint here but none of
the other evidence suggests that then
you know my radar is on high
alert and the other thing is that people
aren't that good at at faking you know
psychosis if somebody's truly psychotic
truly paranoid when I come in some chump
in a waste coat theyve never met before
they usually very very guarded and it
takes a lot of time to elicit you know
symptoms out of them because they think
I'm part of the system I'm part of the
conspiracy right whereas somebody's
trying to fake it they will tell me
within minutes you know I'm hearing
voices doctor or can you see that you
know vampire in the corner doctor so
yeah people are not good at faking
mental illness did lobotomies work uh
I'm ashamed to say this as a
psychiatrist but absolutely not so
lobotomies were a cruel um quite an evil
Twisted thing so lobotomies remove your
prefrontal cortex so either the actual
part of your brain or the connections to
it and this part of your brain is
responsible for things like executive
functions so decision making uh
planning understanding emotions
and sort of sequencing out your thoughts
and your behaviors by removing that you
stopple the issues with that and it was
invented for diseases like schizophrenia
bipolar but the problem is it it kind of
made it turned patients into zombies at
a stretch you could say that it was it
it improved the conditions of some
patients who were so extreme and so
uncontained in their emotions and so
violent that they became kind of docile
dribbling wrecks but obviously this is a
very cruel thing to happen so in the 60s
and 70s uh they they were it people
realized that that the the the cons
heavily outweighed the pros it's kind of
like trying to fix a house with a water
leak by blowing up the house you do get
rid of the water leak but you know at
what cost does anybody have the
potential to commit a serious
crime uh yes sadly is my answer so there
is a the a criminology Theory called
Stakes of commitment made by Hershey in
1969 and that basically says that every
potentially commit a crime if they have
enough to lose so the reason that the
average person doesn't commit a crime is
because it would affect their freedom
going to prison it would affect their
status it would affect their
relationship with their families it
would affect their Lifestyles their
commitment to their jobs to education
but if you lose those things so if if
you don't have them in the first place
or if they're taken away from you then
the boundaries and the barriers to
commit crime reduce so potentially
anybody can I suppose that's in terms of
you know pre-planned crimes in in terms
of impulsive crimes from my experience
absolutely I've seen people who have got
no kind of criminal record who lose It
In the Heat of a moment an argument
usually about um some sort of
relationship problem or argument within
a relationship or jealousy they can lose
it they can attack people um drugs so
I've seen people who've gone on massive
drug Bing binges who either just become
disinhibited or become psychotic drug
induced psychotics who do unspeakable
unimaginable things stabbing killing
sexual assaults and also you know mental
illness so that's my specialty right so
even though I would like to make the
point that the vast majority of people
with a mental illness are not dangerous
a small proportion are and those are the
people that I see so I've seen people
who have never committed any acts of
violence and then do something extremely
violent because they have these
delusional beliefs at the time that the
person they're attacking is dangerous
for some reason do you H ever have
empathy for
criminals absolutely I do so an
uncomfortable truth that I found out
through my line of work that I don't
think I fully appreciated through my
training is that the vast majority of
the defendants that I see were in some
ways victims themselves so even though
they've sometimes done horrible horrible
things they themselves have experienced
physical emotional sexual abuse um
they've grown up in environments where
there's a lot of criminality there's a
lot of violence there's a lot of drug
use so yeah I do feel empathy for that I
can feel you can feel empathy or I can
feel empathy for the person that
separate from the horrific thing that
they've done and I think you have to do
that if you're wanting to rehabilitate
so yeah I think I have empathy for the
more most kind of vulnerable
perpetrators is Lucy letby a psychopath
that is a great question short answer is
no so Lucy letby uh is a case that like
most of the country I'm fascinated with
and the truth is it's really hard for me
to psychoanalyze her because there's
nothing to go on it's like the
equivalent of a pathologist being given
like a dead body with no injuries and
and asking for the cause of death I
don't know the answer she wasn't
antisocial she didn't have any trauma
that we know of in her life she didn't
have any kind of hostility or problems
in her relationships with her work
colleagues there was there was nothing
kind of pathologically wrong with her
emotional makeup and there's very little
Clues to what her motivations were but
to answer your question was she a
psychopath obviously what she did hugely
lacked empathy obviously she was she was
manipulative
I mean she lied and she hid her actions
but I don't think that she particularly
was good at conning or charming people
so I don't think she had those kind of
aspects she wasn't criminally versatile
she wasn't particularly sexually
promiscuous so no I don't think she was
a psychopath for all of those reasons I
I I can't I can't answer the question of
why she did what she did which is quite
infuriating for me do Psychopaths cry so
I
suppose psychopath don't feel emotions
to the same degree that most people do
most emotions whether that's you know
they can feel anger but they don't they
definitely don't feel empathy they feel
sadness but probably to to not to the
same depths that we do they don't feel
fear so do they cry I think they can cry
but I think the likelihood of them
crying is lower and the threshold for
them to get upset is much much higher
and if they do cry it's usually for a
selfish reason so I don't think a
psychopath would truly cry because
something bad has happened to somebody
else that they love love a true
psychopath would only cry because
something you know something something
that's damaged them or their future has
happened so I guess what I'm saying is
they'll they'll cry but only for selfish
reasons can a head injury change your
personality yeah absolutely so
especially if it's your frontal Globe so
right the front of your brain so the
frontal Globe is in charge of higher
executive function so like decision
decision
making controlling your emotions
controlling your personality
understanding the emotions of other
people planning sequences is all done by
your frontal robe right so if you have a
specific injury whether it's a tumor or
a stroke or even like a physical bullet
wound or something though it's very rare
it can completely change your
personality so it can make people really
impulsive it can make them quite
disinhibited so I've assessed a woman
once who was in her 60s who was
completely normal before she was middle
class a bit prudish middle AG well 60s
uh and then overnight she suddenly
changed she became quite sexually
promiscuous she had affairs out of the
blue lots of them in a short space of
time she was going to like orgies the
reason that she came to my attention was
because she got arrested for threatening
her nextdoor neighbor who she'd been
friends with for like 20 years over some
argument about putting the bins
out or something and it was only
afterwards when she was on remand that
she had an MRI scan and it showed that
she had a very specific stroke in a
frontal herb so yeah overnight she
changed in her personality which serial
killer would you like like to meet I
would have to say Ted Bundy
because um he again he he's somebody
he's been diagnosed as a true psychopath
he was apparently really really Charming
so obviously he Charmed his victims into
a false Social Security but aside from
that he actually Charmed some of the
police officers who are investigating
him he Charmed some of the reporters to
to kind of give positive stories about
him and I'm just genuinely intrigued to
know if armed with that advice whether I
would fall for his charms or not or
whether I'd see through it all do you
think there'll be attempts on Lucy ley's
life in prison I think that there are
prisoners uh in the women's estate who
will think nothing of trying to get a
trophy uh like Lucy Lippy